How'd you make is it? I do [motorbike] [currying] [on] [a] can?
I'm gonna go and see my boyfriend. He's an artist [a] street artist
Whooping it's guys you guys
Go pick of that person
You inspire me. Do you think [that] the street are still has a rebellious edge? Oh definitely?
Yeah, frozen unless you're after that wall can we speak out me no, I'm good, but I will call you after my dinner
No me the little circle. This is the my boyfriend no picking up those
You don't take pictures you know keeping that person?
capital most Prestigious Department store
Look, I like your brother. I like his friends there. They're cool, but I just I want you to know that
I'm by your side, [so]
[you] got robbed in my brother that mob is out there looking, huh, shut up, shut up
We have graffiti art fetching six-figure sums in some galleries, but the heat on you now boys. You better bury yourself
This is a [once] [in] [a] [lifetime] score
She probably got off the gangs in West London [ah] [thea]
Bring the job [before] you're looking at the face [value]. He's 20 million quid [I]
Hate violence, they are naughty I'm sleepy you little bitch town. I'm just not used to
Detective Sergeant Baxter from trident and became done unit the other little turn Queens evidence the first chance they get I love you, too
How much money guns are paid to stay silent?
It's no use to you know. He's got the details or something you might be interested in
I'm glad you don't hang out with your brother those dudes nothing pulling you down or constant
They do not call me [that] [Chris] said that you [should] handle it. It's a big [job]
serious amount of money we might
The ice machine go ahead